this is no ordinary rabbit this is the  New England Cottontail a species that's  been pushed to the limits of its  survival nearly identical to it's much  more common cousin the eastern  cottontail the elusive New England  Cottontail is found only in a few  isolated pockets of its former habitat  that once ran from Maine to New York  City these rabbits have acute eyesight  and hearing when they sense danger they  will typically freeze in place relying  on their gray brown fur to camouflage  them but when they need to run their  powerful launches allow them to reach  top speeds of 80 miles per hour but  unfortunately their speed can't save  them from invasive species and a loss of  habitat the New England Cottontail is  very existence now hangs in the balance  this is a New England Cottontail rabbit  [Music]